I could not be more thrilled than to
have this guest sitting to my right who
I will stop talking about like he's not
sitting here the Academy Award winner
himself in a new movie only the brave
about the Granite Mountain hotshots
couldn't be more timely and it's a
terrific film I've seen it you should
see it Friday October 20th with Jeff
Bridges right here on the show good to
see you Jeff good to be here thanks for
coming in here thank you for coming in
you're you bet so I don't even know
where to start with you except obviously
you have many films to your credit in
your career was there any sports film
that you ever got a chance to try out
and yeah I guess stock car racing that's
a sport I played junior Johnson kind of
one of the guys who kicked off that
sport right and I was in a movie called
against all I recall that I got to play
a wide receiver hung out with Bob
Chandler a little bit learned a bit
about that so what do you mean you've
because you know you played a a football
player on the back side of a career
that's right yeah things kind of weren't
going your way
those were the odds that you were
against yeah in a way yeah that's right
I hung out with a Bob Chandler he was
kind enough to give me some tips and we
met at a restaurant and I remember he
got in the chair and he was like he was
like slowly sitting Joe Lee sitting down
and getting up this family and he says
yeah I'm just gonna play well maybe one
more season maybe two I see you're
kidding me you feeling like that he says
yeah show up you know hours before the
game and they you know getting the table
and they've shooting me up with some
stuff I like it move and I say well why
are you doing that Bob and he says
catching that long ball there's nothing
like it hmm
he says you know I feel like every time
I catch that ball I feel like weeping
just from ecstasy you know it's such you
know I'm with all those guys I can't be
crying on the field but that's what it
feels like and right so he's it was
worth you know going through that kind
of pain and you were and you put that
into your character in the film it was
very helpful also another sports movie
that comes to mind is a Seabiscuit I
didn't you know I wrote in it but I
didn't
right in the races but got to play you
know Howard the owner of Cephas he got
worked with Gary Davis who's you know
great jockey mm-hmm you got to meet
those guys to be around it was get
around horses that's an amazing Express
the most dangerous sport in the world I
think just getting on a well no they I
mean yeah they you know stock car you
got in the cage if you know these
jockeys they're just out there yes oh my
god sitting on well I mean you've you've
written many horses since yeah yeah I
love to ride yeah Jeff Bridges here on
the rich Johnson show did you ever try
sports did you ever try to play it
before you guys well you know Mike I
guess my sport I always have a sport it
would be surfing that I just figured
obviously your laid-back dude so that's
right and you know tennis my dad was a
big tennis player and my brother Bo hmm
he was really the sport guy I mean his
growing up he's my big brother you know
eight years older and he taught me you
know all the sports your how to throw a
curve ball in Little League and I did I
did some of that but bo he was scouted
by the Dodgers he played under that
right played under wooden at UCLA you
know and he's not a tall guy but he
played with your Walt Hazzard and that
sure yeah yes the bow is the he's the
real sports guy so John Wooden coaching
overall yeah that's so yeah that's it
that's his legendary City since that's
something yeah yeah
what would you what is your favorite
sports movie before we get into your
films well you know Raging Bull popped
in my head that was a oh and I did a
boxing movie - with John Huston Fat City
I forgot about that John Huston yeah
that's a sport movie okay yeah for sure
age Stacy Keach hmm
so you Raging Bull leaps to mind popped
into my head some other good ones well I
guess I mean there's the cut there's the
the you know bang the drum slowly
there's you know what I thought was the
one that Tab Hunter was in Damn Yankees
yeah yeah you're going old school yeah
well I remember ditching school to watch
that movie when I
sodding the TV guy Jeff Bridges here on
the Rich Eisen show so your current film
let's talk about this right now because
it couldn't be more timely with
wildfires in other than California yeah
wildfires here in Southern California
it's only the brave about the Granite
Mountain hotshots a group of elite fire
fighters that it was the largest loss of
firefighters since September 11th in the
Yarnell fire that took place in June of
2013 what did you learn about this type
of American Miss human being these human
beings that fight these fires well I've
appreciated firefighters for a long time
I've lost a house and a malibu fire we
lost 400 acres up in a ranch in Montana
due to wildfires so I know these you
know these guys and I so appreciate what
they what they go through of course when
you do a movie and you you meet these
you know they meet the real guys I was
fortunate enough to actually work with
Dwayne Steinberg who was who was the
actual guy that I play the wildland
division Fire Chief of Prescott Arizona
he was but he had retired a year before
this Yarnell fire but he was very
instrumental in bringing the hotshots
together and getting their certification
and it was so great to have him on board
as well as a Brendan McDonough who was
the lone survivor of this terrible fire
so and as I said before the movie it's
you know it certainly an important
element is this tragic aspect to it but
it's really centers on who these guys
were you know and it turns out that they
was just as imperfect as us you know
they're just normal guys they got their
demons that they're facing but they they
practice this brave this bravery you
know and that's something that I was
left with after watching the movie we
saw it again for the second time they
had the premiere a couple of nights ago
and you know it's inspiring when you
look at these guys who risked their
lives so selflessly you know
you think well what what what in my life
where can I be more brave where can I
show up and make a difference like these
guys okay and I just watching it myself
Jeff I thought again of the people who
are currently fighting and 100-degree
well yeah your whether running towards
the fire when people's houses are in
dangers maybe they don't even know what
these people are that's right and their
bedrooms yeah and they just want to save
these lives and I did think that too or
I'm just thinking like so what what
about me yeah introspective in that
anyway I was very pleased to know that
the producers of the film they've been
the whole movie has been really
supported by the families of the guys
who perished and the producers of the
film have set up Bay Granite Mountain
fund so people can go to only the brave
- movie.com and they can contribute to
this Granite Mountain hotshots fund that
supports these hotshots that you know
protect us against these fires so we're
get seeing so many of them you know it's
terrible it is more but in its it like I
said it's timely Taylor Kitsch who's in
it a lot of sports fans know from fun
night like he's wonderful he's terrific
in it Josh Brolin miles Taylor James
badge Dale and Jennifer Connelly who
I've had a crush on since forever
wasn't she something man in the movie oh
yes she was yeah I paint Josh Brolin's
wife yeah il me you are you're the best
man I'd love to sit here in just 60
seconds we come back I want to talk some
more about some of your films that I've
been a fan of for quite some time we'll
talk some Lebowski sure you've done
hopefully you will abide when we come
back in 60 seconds here with Jeff
Bridges on the Rich Eisen show
all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show the Academy Award winning actor in
only the brave and theaters near you
coming up on October 20th Jeff Bridges
here on the Rich Eisen show I want to go
over some of the films of yours that I
have been big fan of for quite some time
already talked about against all odds
Tron could technically be a sports movie
would you say I mean yeah we did some
sports in that it gets frisbee it would
form the frisbee I mean not just any
sort of when you were doing it did you
have any idea of the video game culture
that was busting out and in our country
at the time and that that tap did you
know when you said that video game and
Steven list burger the director and the
writer of that film yeah
Tron was his first film and he came up
with the idea said this is a you know
all about the being sucked into a video
game so he thought it was a good idea to
line the walls of our studio with video
games that you didn't have to pay for
them were just on board and it was it
was a wonderful idea
in one sense and there was a lot of fun
but I'd also kind of slowed the shooting
down because you get locked in mad
there's a game called what was it tank a
battle zone okay you remember that Jam
and I was locked into that man oh god
and they would say oh come on you have
already to [ __ ]
oh man I'm preparing I'm preparing my
rocks and I would get locked into that
but see we're in a pacman God and they
have that to a head pac-man all the
proof pong you know we had pong I do
that thinking of pong yeah you know
Harry Dean Stanton just I just passed
away yeah if you google Harry Dean
Stanton and Jeff Bridges pong yes you'll
see a huge scene it was amazing that the
director lingered on this shot but I
think it's very effective of the Harry
Dean and my reflection in the pong game
a movie called Rancho deluxe where I met
my wife you know 45 years ago and Harry
Dean and I are doing this scene ever of
thought to put Jeff Bridges and Harry
Dean Stanton in the same
oh yeah you know that's that's good one
right there
then star man I always think of from the
line from star man every time the light
turns yellow at an intersection because
of the or line star man I know yeah yeah
I know I know all about how to drive
what a green go red stop yellow go very
fast is when I asked Charlie I think
Charlie Martin Smith or Karen Allen
Willard or towards the end of the movie
I say you know what I like about human
beings the most is when things are at
their worst you were at your best I'm
not pretty
it's a neat movie star man is a really
good one yeah for sure
jagged edge is well right in the middle
of the 80s where you were you what is
your role on spoilers right now I mean
is it safe to talk about the end of
jagged edge even though well I want to
see a movie
I wouldn't know as little about it as
possible do you like that mean you when
you're lucky to you not get enough to
see a movie having know nothing about it
every once in a while I'll experience a
movie like that I remember going to a
Rosemary's Baby I'm sure on a matinee
and I had know nothing about it and
after that movie I was sure that all the
theater attendants were war locked my
god but spoilers that's a pretty old
movie but what were you gonna say a
jagged-edged I mean those who might not
have seen it is your philosophy on on
that skip the the twist you know okay so
we don't know I said there's a twist
that was there's a twist of no problem
yeah and then let's get to it with the
Big Lebowski
how are you introduced to that film do
you just get a script or no I ran to the
Coen brothers
a couple of years before that I guess
and had a party in this who are writing
something for you
I say oh great cuz I was a big fan of
Blood Simple and some other early as
your own and then I got the script and I
said what
this isn't that not like anything I've
done were you were you spying and we did
you crash some of my high school parties
and you let me worry where did this guy
come from but I was thrilled to to work
with those guys they're real they're
real masters they know how to do it
was that character based on anybody that
you know yes based on the guy named Jeff
Dowd for them you know they used him
quite a bit I met him he came on the
script I didn't use him too much I
really referenced myself and the script
yeah so you are how much the dude is in
you that's where I that's where I start
when I prepare for any film I think
about aspects of myself that kind of
paralleled the character and I might
magnify certain aspects ones that don't
fit a kick to the curb but that's it you
know that's the beginning play you know
when Mary's ophrys the costume designer
we met at my home and I said you know
we've tried a bunch of stuff I said well
you come up to my closet let's just look
around and she said what are these weird
jelly shoes here so yeah those are good
for the dude let's put those and oh look
what's this t-shirt what's this weird
Japanese lettering over this baseball
guy what is that yeah so we just you
know used a lot of my stuff what about
the cardigan the cardigan sweater is
that yours no that was that was Mary's
but I scored the guy scored that
afterwards where's that cardigan it's on
the wooden statue of Howe type a
bodhisattva
you know character and I he's wearing my
sweater in your house yeah is that right
so that exists yes White Russians where
did that come from that was just in the
squares in the screen oh yeah okay yeah
and given the choice would you roll on
Shabbos or not
well that's my partner I know I have no
problem really good job I mean did you
when did you realize that this film
would become in many ways hey you can't
even call to college it's a classic it's
just flat-out classic now yeah yeah I
was surprised because we had a great
time making it and we were all you know
laugh at him you know thinking you know
this was a fun movie we didn't think it
was gonna be anything like it was today
but I was surprised when it first came
out and did nothing it was like kind of
a bomb and then it played in Europe and
they got it and then it splashed back
over on our shores and you know he grew
to become one of our colleagues on the
show Jeff Bridges here on the on the
show for a couple more minutes one of
the colleagues on our show here as a
friend who went to alibi or in Iceland
we got these we have Lebowski Fest
I've been to her I played with my band
at a little bow ski fan that was my
Beatle moment playing to a sea of dudes
and bowling pins
oh my god it is like a psychedelic
journey in itself right basically it's
just it's just such a great movie
executed so well and like many masters
you know the Coen Brothers make it look
like it's just nothing it's falling off
a log yeah but when you really look at
it man it is executed yeah they're so
brilliant other geniuses I mean phrasing
Arizona we could go on and on about
Roger Deakins the cinematographer did
such a beautiful job and you're not you
don't think of it as you know didn't you
have a movie that you know it's shot
beautifully but if you look at that
movie the camera is right with just
where you wanna it's nothing show and
there's no showing off it's just
everything is just right Oh a couple
more minutes with Jeff Bridges here now
I want to talk about your dad for a
second yeah okay your Lord know was in I
don't know how many movies he was in
over a hundred or highly
and then he just a couple of things
about him that maybe fans might not know
about your dad even though I know I do
and there's a bunch of people but
airplane okay some of your dad's been to
some great movies and some great TV
shows but he played the role a belief of
mccroskey oh yeah in airplane some of
the more famous lines about picking the
wrong week we got as the kids you know
his kids we got such a kick out of it
he's playing a total drug addict and it
was the entities of who he was a real
life it was such a hell freak but in the
picture right there what is it like
seeing your dad I kind of know tiny
yellow shorts you are sure you know my
father had a huge hit on TV called Sea
Hunt in the 60s played as skin diver and
he played it so well that people thought
he was a skin diver and it was great
news financially for him because you
know really you know we moved into a new
big house and everything after that but
it was kind of depressing for him as an
actor because he developed this strong
persona that people thought that's who
he was and he was offered a lot of
skin-diving scripts you know you'll play
this Kananga no no but he saw the the
downside of developing a very strong
persona because he was you know he knew
Shakespeare was great comedian he was in
you mentioned movies High Noon you know
Gary Cooper and so I in Mike early my
career I really tried hard not to
develop a strong persona because I saw
how my dad struggled with it so now we
cut years later to a movie that we
talked about called blown away and I'm
talking to the producer and I say
there's a wonderful actor who could be
I'd like you to consider for my playing
my uncle he kind of looks like me he's a
good acting and the guy says all he
laughs he said oh yeah Lloyd Bridges
he's wonderful but he's really more of a
comedian I said what are you talking
about he says well you know airplane
people are gonna the baggage I sell
you're gonna make him read for the
parties who would he read for the hawk
so he comes in he knocks it out of the
park you know and he is he plays my
uncle so a guy who try to avoid being
typecast as a sea diver was watch out
and you're too good at something you get
lucky looks like I picked the wrong week
to stop drinking and smoking and then he
was on Seinfeld Seinfeld as Mandelbaum
that's right what was that like watching
your dad at the end of his career on an
iconic television show like that it was
wonderful he you know was his health was
you know kind of you know failing him
then and but whenever he got onstage or
in front of the camera you know he
started lifting weights hey Jeff like I
said I'm a huge fan of yours I could go
on and on and on crazy heart for which
you won your your Oscar hell or high
water terrific True Grit
I loved I mean last picture show as well
going way back and now only the brave in
theaters on October 20th come back
please any time we'll really wouldn't
enjoy then great by the way hey you know
the one hand the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy